[Music]
so welcome to what I think is number 21
or number 22 of our worlds of
speculative fiction series we're
finishing up the Year Strong with
Octavia Butler used to be called
xenogenesis now they call it a Lillis
brewed trilogy and so we're gonna talk
primarily about that you you know all of
you are old hands at this now so you
know we talk a little bit about
biography some preliminary remarks then
jump into the world building and boy
she's she's doing a lot of that in this
this work the narrative world is
extremely rich and very alien and then
we'll talk about some philosophical
themes that I picked up we can always
talked about whatever you guys were
struck by in it I I found some
interesting you know quotations by her
from from a number of different
interviews one essay as well that that I
think are going to be kind of useful so
I'm going to begin with with the first
one this is from writers and books she
was asked you know what kind of writer
she is is she a sci-fi writer and she
said I consider myself a writer as
you're probably aware it's unbelievably
boring to have people continually trying
to get you to define or are you writing
speculative fiction or science fiction
and she says is it a good story that's
what's really key if so accepted is that
well then she went on to talk a little
bit about her biography she says I don't
think my mother had any awareness of
science fiction or any other genre she
had only three years of education she
was pulled out of school early to be put
to work
my grandmother was widowed about the
time ah come on in the the Depression
started this meant that a lot of her
older children they are poor anyway it
didn't get to get an education she was
glad I was inside reading because if I
was in the house reading I wasn't out
getting into trouble and maybe I might
survive so science fiction for her you
know she's got a very different attitude
towards towards you know writing and
reading and in general and she says I
think the reading was not nearly as
suspect as the writing
I think the family that I know is her
family were alarmed I actually imagined
I could earn a living writing stories
right which is a bit difficult prospect
it's interesting how many science
fiction writers actually get going when
they're very young I was on a program
with Greg Barrett he mentioned he'd
gotten started writing when he was 8 I
began writing when I was 10 she says I
think we're influenced by the stuff we
find it and we love it were influenced
by it I know I collected my first
rejection slip when I was 13 and went
out collecting them for a long time
after that so that that's kind of a good
segue into talking about her her
biography you know like a lot of the
people that we've looked at she had some
periods where the same like she couldn't
sell anything she had to struggle
against you know sort of taking
rejection to too much to heart and and
stopping writing because of that so why
don't we start with with the biography
so she's born in Pasadena and her you
know mother and father will get married
but her father dies when she's pretty
young so he's out of the picture she
moves she and her mother moved in with
her her mother's family they're pretty
strongly religious they're growing up in
Pasadena which to some degree was you
know less segregated than many cities
you know Octavia Butler and her family
are for African Americans so the soldier
she got to see quite a bit of racial
dynamics at work at a time when you know
this is long before
well the civil rights struggle is going
on but it's long before the legislation
is going into to work she recalls you
know like going along with her mother to
work her mother worked as a maid and she
got to see how how these sorts of
dynamics played out and she also you
know starts writing stories and she's 10
she convinces her mother to buy her a
typewriter and apparently these weren't
science fiction stories she said there
were horsies stories which I don't know
much about them yeah I was you know
that is a nice but that is supposed to
especially at that that time you know
there's a lot of steering girls towards
that and then something really
interesting happens that I actually
thought was worth putting into the the
by the biographical timeline she sees
this sci-fi movie from about I think
five years before called devil girls
from Mars I don't actually know anything
about it and she says in her interviews
it was a terrible movie yeah why
probably yeah it was probably one of
those like yeah like we had shock
theater and somewhat Svengoolie and so
there was probably that and she gets
convinced you cheated her response to it
is I could do better than that and so
she starts writing science fiction stuff
and that's when like the the you could
say the the outlines or the catalyst for
the pattern is novel is that she's going
to write start getting put down on paper
so she's you know like a lot of a lot of
the people that we've looked at they
started writing pretty early and they
didn't worry an awful lot about what
would you say like finding writing
exactly the right way they're kind of
puttering around with it and seeing what
worked she was kind of I mean she talks
about being very tall very early not
having a good time with other kids
getting bullied by them and staying
inside quite a bit she graduates from
from high school and she starts working
odd jobs and attending Pasadena City
College working on her associates and
she graduates from there in about three
years
with an associates in history and then
goes to California State College in Los
Angeles changes from that to doing
writing courses with UCLA but but
continues working like all these
different jobs here and there and her
writing she said would often happen
sort of in the wee hours of the night so
again like some of the other people that
we've we've looked at before they make
it big I mean in the end she really does
make it big in a very unique way well I
know you're going through the yeah but
the MacArthur thing attracted your
attention because you got the genius she
did she is the yeah she is the first
like person awarded that for science
fiction yeah yes they they they gave it
to her it wasn't I think that was like a
million bucks right okay so back then it
was two hundred and twenty something
thousand so I guess it's going up quite
a bit and that really helped her out she
also at one point for her store for her
novel kindred after she'd already
published a couple other novels she got
a $5,000 advance so that would have been
in the mid 70s that would have gone a
long ways five thousand dollars back
then she talked about that and a few
interviews are you gonna talk about why
the xenogenesis trilogy became out of
print and then reissued as this dad I
don't actually know but I think we may
have somebody who might know I'm
probably popular demand right didn't
come back after she died that's a good
question so it could Willis brood was
been published posthumously but it was a
reissue of the registry regional yeah
yeah I mean the xenogenesis was the one
that I that was the name under which I
was reading that any for this one the
first trade edition is two thousand so
she was still alive originally publishes
the xenogenesis trilogy which which has
actually kind of cooler cover art than
this this looks kind of looks lot I know
yeah Carol and read something up and
then turned it into like you know a
western planets and stuff
but you know with a kindred novel they
were trying to talk her into turning it
into like a romance novel and this is
after she published a few actual novels
so she you know I guess the the the
store the the the mountain that that the
model the moral of the story is you're
never so big that people won't try to
sell you on doing something different
with your work what that dude is up now
jumping back a little bit one one of the
things that I think was really key for
her she then she talks about this again
many interviews was participating in
this open door program that the screen
guild writers of America had and it was
supposed to you know promote young poor
you know all including also minority
writers sort of an outreach program and
and these sorts of things she said
really important because otherwise she
wasn't coming into contact with with you
know people like her and and so getting
together these writing workshops was
really important she also meets Harlan
Ellison there and Harlan Ellison takes
an interest in her career and winds up
you know making connections for her he
was a very assertive guy to say the
least
some might might call him you know more
on the aggressive scale and he's wanted
to suggest that she go to the Clarion
Science Fiction Writers Workshop which
means she leaves California and and and
travels there she meets Samuel Delaney a
number of other people it's a six-week
program and that opens the door for her
and her first work
her first novella is published in the
anthology that comes out of that so
that's what kind of opens the door for
her you notice that there's a long gap
from 1971 to 1976 she's unable to
actually get anybody to buy her stuff
she keeps working on things gets a lot
of rejection letters and can't can't
seem to get any traction and then things
start to click and she you know starts
to get
recognized and like I mentioned gets an
advance she uses part of that to travel
by Greyhound across the United States
getting to see different different parts
and you know by the 1980s she's getting
recognized you know in terms of awards
and I'll I only actually put some of the
awards that she received on here and
she's you know pretty consistent with
with writing and you know development of
these these stories she you know she
works in terms of what would you call it
like large-scale projects like like this
three novels then each you know continue
a common pattern and she doesn't just
stick with one narrative world like some
of the authors that we've looked at
where they almost you you I mean if we
want to be a little derogatory we'd said
they ride it you know into the dust or
you know we might say they milk it for
everything it's worth she doesn't she
doesn't do that when she thinks that
something is done she's she moves on to
the next project she ended up traveling
quite a bit and working some of that
like you know when she was traveling to
the Amazon and the Andes she was doing
that in part for research on these these
novels and as you put it uh she she wins
the MacArthur Genius grant
she said they didn't measure my IQ so
I'm not sure that I am a genius but you
know that's pretty good and she she dies
pretty young unfortunately really cut
short they think that she probably had a
stroke and then she she falls sustained
some injuries she was only 56 when she
dies and so it cut her career short but
but already she had accomplished you
know quite a lot there's a whole string
of novels she was teaching people how to
write she was conducting these workshops
she it was enough of a writer took gone
through a dry spell with rejection slips
and a dry spell with writer's block and
still
produce a lot of stuff so and you know
that kinda tells you a good bit about
her and you know I have some other
things that are sort of her reflections
on her own process so I thought those
would be interesting to look at she
talks about science fiction I think this
is a common experience being a boy genre
she said it was white it was an
adolescent it involved a particular kind
of adolescent best described as a nerd
this did not make it popular with blacks
or adults or women for quite a long time
but then some of the bestsellers she
says I think helped to draw people in
who otherwise would never touch science
fiction a lot of the science fiction
writers have gotten older a little
better accepted some of them still write
very well and their books bring people
in and then she points out science
fiction writers come from science
fiction readers you know and I think
this is this is more true today perhaps
then than it was even back then you know
people there's so many people writing
now and where did they get the impetus I
mean they suppose there could be a few
people trying to make a buck right or
they're like I'm going to go into this
genre because it's really gonna pay but
I don't think science fiction is as a
job like that because there's so many
people doing it and there's so much
scrutiny now of your stuff people are
always ready to say oh this is awful
derivative no good so I think you know
it's it's quite important in order to
have good science fiction being
generated we need good models of what's
counting a science fiction and and she's
sort of like one of the people who we
talked about last year Michael Moorcock
in that she's you know constantly
pushing the envelope trying to see where
where else it could go then I think that
comes out very strongly in these novels
in particular where you've got you know
I was joking with somebody who I was
talking with earlier today said you know
I don't really know those and I said
well the people who attend they're
either gonna be you know pretty
interested in the stuff that she's
talking about were they're gonna be this
just stood by it because you know she's
talking about sexuality in in very frank
terms you've got inter species mating
going on the question of whether the
human race is actually going to survive
because of this all this sexual gene
crossing and so you know I think there's
there's something there to be said about
that I think this is the sort of stuff
that you know maybe science fiction
authors from a generation before her
might have totally turned their nose up
at but you know we see people like
Moorcock and farmer and Butler really
pushing the limits on what could be what
could fit into the frame of science
fiction Ursula K Le Guin - I would say
kind of fits into that as well so she
says I think there's more and more
blacks begin to read science fiction
then more blacks will take up writing
science fiction this is already
happening to a certain degree she says I
came into science fiction when things
were opening up for women when it was
okay to notice the fact that the
universe wasn't just white or male so I
could write about black women black
heroines and not get anybody upset I got
readers who wrote me letters wondering
why there always seem to be a black
person I work but most people seemed
either to accept it or shut up about it
and that's coming from the black scholar
interview in 1986 so I mean that's a
long time ago already things were
starting to change and then there's
there's that other one where she talks
about what what influences her she you
know not only does writing influence her
she says anything that I come in contact
with and I start researching influences
me so she you know travels to the Amazon
and the Andes and a lot of that goes
into the descriptions of the environment
and the fauna in this one so that's a
lot of talking on my part before we go
into the narrative world what were you
know what were your
I need that question in terms of just
goes beyond it gets her yeah is it I
mean I so look at the biography timeline
and you know we're getting in I mean is
sometimes younger I guess and some of
the other authors but I mean yeah you
look at the 1970s and 1980s and I think
maybe because of the television series
or the movies that were starting to come
out that science fiction became more
mainstream so I'm just wondering of
whether that created opportunities for
authors like her who might live distant
or not seemingly connected with a lot of
others yeah writers whether there was
sort of starting to reach out from afar
and communicate back and forth and talk
about it just read your book you know
yeah you know there was more of that
going on I I don't know it's it's yeah
you know what she actually talks about
she credited Star Wars in particular for
really opening things up particularly
for audiences that otherwise weren't
going to be interested in science
fiction's you know like in that black
scholar interview she talks about listen
black people went and watch Star Wars
and then we're like okay this this is
pretty cool stuff
now we're gonna read other authors and
you know if you think about so we had
Star Trek which was late 60s right into
the early seventies I think so it didn't
make it into the 70s and then what would
be like the next really big we had
Battlestar Galactica which only lasted
two seasons space 1999 which I think was
kind of popular which might have been a
bit earlier did we have any other really
big sci-fi seems like The Twilight Zone
yeah it kind of put you you know out
there's something different you know
they are otherworldly and those things
are big days yeah but yeah I think I
think you guys are right that there
that's true yeah yeah
so other media is is opening up the door
to print science-fiction oh yeah I mean
they're there if we think about cartoons
or probably we're quite a few sci-fi
cartoons show the sticks no but I think
you're right a lot of that stuff created
an environment where science fiction can
kind of move out of the you might call
it the pulp ghetto right and so she you
know she's and she's writing at the
right time for that and she's got
somebody who is helping her out to which
is you know Harlan Ellison very
polarizing guy but if he was on your
side I think that would help out quite a
bit because he would get in people's
faces probably I don't I don't know
enough about this her biography but I'd
be willing to bet that Harlan Ellison
probably helped her from getting screwed
over on some deals to his he was a very
hard-nosed
guy in that way I just think you know
it's it seems like as a writer of
science fiction or speculative fiction
it's a financial challenge is following
yourself so visit a hobby for somebody
like this in they want to commit more
time but they got to live so they're
really working it you have different
things we don't know about and yeah they
also want to develop as a writer and so
I have reaching out when it becomes more
popular and goofy things like
long-distance rates reduce dramatically
so you can now have you know oh we have
a long conversation it's like now we
think of the internet which opened up a
lot of contact all over the place you
don't even know where some people are
physically how did you know but I mean
so maybe somewhere in here there was a
lot of development going on and
influences that we just don't know I
think I think that's that's probably
completely right yeah it was you know
the sort of thing that she is
experiencing might not have had
say in the 1930s that right you know
yeah I think that that's probably true
well she was seen as the first
african-american woman in science
fiction right yeah ever I don't know
that she was the first ever yeah that's
how she was seen no she didn't do any
work for the starter - it seemed like a
lot of the authors no writer for Star
Trek I mean they brought in different
people to do different episodes and
things I mean she because it was a
multiracial cast from the beginning yeah
yeah but yeah yeah I mean notice she's
she's just graduating from Pasadena City
College in 68 so yeah she's not
well-established everything she's not
gone to those workshops yeah yeah I mean
it's interesting because being out in
California this is a total speculation I
think it would have been more possible
for her to like write for television
yeah right but she you know she seems to
like she had all these jobs and she
would do jobs you know she didn't get to
you know she didn't get a trash she
didn't get sentimental about jobs a job
was just there to earn money so she
could do her thing you know and and and
also sometimes so she could do research
that would go into a story she said and
and you know if she could make it just
by writing then she was good with that
but she did it through you know writing
novels she I don't think she you know
really thought well III can't say this
it doesn't appear that she gave a lot of
thought so I'm trying to write for
television or something like that
I mean yeah because where she lived like
you said the fact that it was too young
no no no industry yeah they look for
somebody to help you know assistant
writer you have episodes you know or
whatever you're in the genre you're
meeting some other people who are
writing yeah it's raising for me
no eccentric I mean came back well now
just our track but there are plenty of
other series going on you know you know
it could have been to that that maybe it
was harder to break in as a woman or you
know being african-american I don't know
enough about solutely they actually say
that during that period of time yeah you
know Michael Apted right think we talked
about him before he did the 7up series
and then oh yeah in 21 like all the
sequential yeah he made all of these in
the movies so that he could fund his
railroad hire which was to continue that
project he said the people in the
documentary world didn't take him
seriously because he had entered into
this other realm and people and the sort
of more popular you know a rocky films
that he made they're just like why are
you still doing that yeah you know so I
think I guess some yeah I guess there's
there's two ways you could go until you
actually have enough recognition that
you can sort of make it with your craft
which is you know you could like just do
something else like sell insurance by
day or you know wheat tables or whatever
and then do your thing or you could do
something that's similar to your thing
like what you're saying he's doing or if
she'd done television writing and then
do what you really really want to do on
the side and I guess she thought that it
was better to do all the unrelated jobs
you know I mean she did get a lot of
material out of she gives examples of
people who you know in a transfigured
way show up later on in her novels you
know so and you know I think some of us
who have writerly aspirations we we
sometimes think about like you know
terrible jobs that we've had and the
things you know in that way right oh no
that's that's what you know he's always
hated to something to make movies
because it's ridiculously expensive
yeah writing isn't that quite so
expensive that's that's kind of a better
proposition in some respects on that
let's talk about the narrative world oh
yeah exactly
although now you can self-publish you
know and somebody will probably buy it
you know at least the copy so and
there's not as much of an onus against
it so the so the narrative world you
know it's very coherent it's very rich
you know like some of the other authors
that we've been looking at there's
there's a essentially a universe being
developed and you know these Huang Kali
are at the the center of it yeah I mean
the story is that human the human race
has managed to almost kill itself off
because of a global thermonuclear war
that pretty much wipes out the the
northern hemisphere which is probably
what would happen if we did have a
nuclear war the people who would be
surviving would be like in South America
or in parts of Africa if that didn't get
nuked or in Australia and so the story
picks up 250 years after the war and it
centers the first book on this woman
Lilith and you know one of the things I
really liked about these stories that I
think Butler is a real strength in her
writing is you know she only reveals
bits and pieces you know then it gets
bigger and bigger and bigger and she
does so much of it through either
description or dialogue and you know
she's these Oh Canali
yeah Oh golly they really are alien they
really are weird but she is able to
describe them in such a way and their
inner life that at least I found I could
I could you know make sense of them and
relate to them and and understand where
they were coming from and they're not
all on the same page either and she's
able to switch back and forth between
humans and on Khali's and these these
hybrids and and through that then she
she lays out this this narrative world I
think it's really quite impressive how
she how does she did that I'm glad that
you suggest that
her breakfast way across her wildest eat
okay
that was where I first came across her
and I find it interesting everybody
focuses on the snacks yeah and I thought
I thought it was more about how do we
define being human
yeah I think that's one of the really
key is really define being civilized how
did you find yeah being a race a species
you know but the economy they were I
mean they they traded in jeans so I mean
what they did is they I mean I read just
someone who I'm trying this book that
was their survival right and so I it was
more of a selfish I mean it was their
survival was based on I'm mixing every
racist look but when I did it kind of it
kind of was a bit here with you know
with the whole arms and all of that
business and I mean it knows obviously
yeah very pleasurable what you know what
because you had to have that personal
there but the two humans were never
loved to touch not even to stroke hair
to do any they could never do any touch
it was didn't want yeah never find a
republic yeah does it seem to me like
they tried well Joseph wasn't it okay
like I think they were trying to have
some kind of contact but I thought there
was not like the Lulu I would say no no
no once they make that connection okay
that was so pleasurable yeah yeah
and that's I mean that's kind of an
interesting point the the humans you
know we were much you might say harder
an edge than they are and much more
towards like we you look we're doing
things this way or this way they kind of
nudge you you know a little bit this you
know you know you know
you we're not going to like you know
force you into things but you can really
only go this way I mean they're very
manipulative and what they do is
actually quite in vase I mean it's
really quite invasive and they do kinda
take away your humanity well let's talk
about the theme then because that was
one I want us roll that was one that I
want I wanted to think about it in terms
of what we call paternalism right so
paternalism is when you make decisions
that affect somebody else and maybe like
closed off options or offer them options
and you you don't give them full
autonomy to participate in that you may
not even give them full knowledge
because the view is it's better for them
and so like you know when Lilith first
comes on the scene early on in the books
they you know they make her stay in the
room with the alien the the long Kali
and you know they don't say listen this
is up to you or anything like that
they they put her in a situation and
then over time she gets more and more
freedoms but they always come with some
sort of cost right and they change her
her genes the sequences so that she
won't get cancer there are a lot of
places in these stories where some of
the characters do like ask for what we
would call informed consent but a lot of
cases it's done it's done without that
and it's done that way to to benefit
them in the view of the Oankali or to
protect somebody else but we do view and
I and I think I gave you Buttler setting
it up in such a way that she also views
some of this as as you said invasive as
like transgressing against people's what
would you saying if their rights against
well they're almost parasitic because
they really can't survive without keep
to do this even though they make it like
this is for your benefit but it is it I
mean they they were surviving before
they come to earth other people other
yeah well I'm the
if you get the impression that they they
love engaging in the trade but there are
the kinds of creatures that if they
couldn't find another species to trade
it sound like they were just shrivel up
and die they would marry it was if they
couldn't find a species to trade with
yeah but it's not because if they don't
do it they're gonna get sick and die
like they're the environment can't
affect them as much it's more they have
a desire they they need sort of like you
think about somebody who says oh if I
don't watch my my favorite show three
hours a day I'm going to get depressed
right it's it's a desire for something
that they have to say or else their
dreams return some species or
celebration if they didn't have it they
weren't going to survive yeah yeah but
think the light in it I mean that was
necessary yeah hmm I I don't know I
didn't I didn't get the impression I got
the impression that we're really on they
adapted other people's genes because
they needed it to to survive but now
they're they're almost indestructible
you know oh you'd be constructs they
call yeah they they were they had we
were destructive Oh Bjorn they had
certain whoa let's try to think yeah
that the kid the son of vodka because
you know they have these one set of
parents then they have these other
there's so many people involved in these
maybe yeah yeah so that's so that's
another good good thing yeah I mean
that's another good thing for us to talk
about this you know her playing around
with we think of sexual reproduction
terms
you know what we call by morphism right
you've got male and female and it goes
all the way like in plants you know
pollen and eggs and seeds and stuff like
that and we do have a few species where
it's they're sort of hermaphroditic and
and you know they mate in other ways
but we don't really have anything where
it takes three to make it work I mean we
have we have relationships where people
might have like a go on it well a
three-way right or a menage a trois or
now the others actually word of trouble
right yeah well polyamorous opens up the
door to like maybe it could be 57 or you
know there could be people coming and
going with this it's definitely three
and it's not just about you know
enjoyment it's about this is the way
that reproduction has to happen and the
reason is because in this this race the
boy is the one who is you know monkeying
around with the genes more than the
others can so you could understand why
you would be needed I mean Ursula K Le
Guin had had a story where there were
there were three people involved and I
forget exactly how it worked in in this
this race on a different planet with no
sexual relations but we don't usually
think of that and so this this winds up
for a lot of the characters seeming kind
of monstrous and so I'm kind of
interested what were your impressions
when you were first reading this for you
like wow that's really gross or well
that's kind of interesting you know or
wow that would never work or at first I
think I just saw it as why I thought it
was kind of neat the fact that they
could manipulate genes and really make
you stronger and healthier and real and
get rid of disease and and but I just
found that very manipulative for some
reason I can't
I found the the on Akali to be something
it I don't kind of manipulative and
greedy or selfish you know like the
Nazis
like that talk to say yeah you said
paternalistic because they thought they
were doing good things for the human
race
yeah they saw the human race as superior
intelligence yeah but with this flaw
hierarchy competition and by taking that
out increasing survival yeah I mean they
call it the contradiction and the
contradiction is is that apparently in
their experience most with most
intelligent races the more intelligent
they get the less hierarchical they are
but with us yeah and so actually that
that's there's some interesting stuff
that she said about why she wrote this
glad I just let's say that's you talk
about that first about the robot Regan
yeah okay so yeah let's jump to like the
second one or during the early part of
the Reagan era there were people who
thought we could win a nuclear war and
rid ourselves in the Soviet empire I
thought there were nuts but they were
there and Reagan got into office in
spite of the fact that he thought a
nuclear war was winnable I got my idea
for the xenogenesis books from Ronald
Reagan because he was advocating this
kind of thing I thought there must be
something basic something really
genetically wrong with us if we're
falling for this stuff and I came up
with these characteristics the aliens
arrived after the war and they tell us
we have these two characteristics that
don't work and play well together
there they are intelligent and they tell
us where the most intelligent species
they've come across but we're also
hierarchical and I put this after the
big work because it's kind of an example
we've one up to ourselves to death just
our tendency to one-up each other as
individuals and groups large and small
it has a greater consequence if you
combine it with intelligence what I
think it's completely true if you have
two elk fighting over who's going to
make food the consequences to them are
pretty minor but if you're going to have
somebody setting off people to war for
egotistical or economic reasons both
hierarchical sorts of reasons so this
tells us what she means by higher
hierarchy you end up with a lot more
dead people when you're throwing nuclear
weapons
pi which is what we were doing back then
you end up with more dead people than
any war before it could have been very
bad so you know that gives you an idea
what she means by this hierarchical
thing we like to dominate each other and
I mean it's kind of interesting because
from a human perspective we would say oh
yeah of course you know everyone's
probably like that and when we look at
our most of our sci-fi it's always like
one species fighting in other species
you know the aliens are coming down and
they're gonna try to dominate us so we
got to get rid of them and all that in
this world were the weirdos we're we're
the aberrant ones somehow and yeah they
if they can just get us to you know not
necessarily totally breed it out but
learn how to how to manage it then we
could be civilized and you know fit to
live in the rest of the cosmos what are
you going to say there was so much in
the early 80s and late seventies about
in vitro fertilization and test-tube
babies and the babies are being born and
the whole idea of genetic intermixing
and the you know sort of was I think
there was a time reticle like where were
movie next you know are we actually
entering down sort of like some of the
you know Nazi philosophies of breeding
these like super children and you know
there's been so many debates and they
were all sort of stewing around that
same time because 78 was the first in
vitro child born in England and then 81
in the United States and there were only
15 we also had during this time increase
in biracial yeah relationships biracial
children yeah that starting to shift
damn there's a lot of concern about that
genetics mixing yeah and but here she
yeah yeah yeah and here I mean it
they're they're forced into that in part
because look you got human race and that
that's all you got so you know if your
mate happens to be somebody who's
Japanese I just go with
she touched on that you realize she was
touching on we see it more clearly today
maybe in its tribalism okay because the
people who was drew yeah Brooke for the
time it was a great tribal well yeah
they were going to be allowed to but
that's because that but that's because
she showed us yeah he argues for that
because the rest of the the aliens were
like no that's that's too bad for them
right so he has to make a case yeah the
purebred yeah in comparison to the camp
with with hybrids compared to the young
to the ones I mean they were constantly
you know they had the guns they were
yeah you know hurting each other out
slaving each other women yep and trying
to steal those children and then hang
them up to make them look more human oh
yeah like that was gonna help yeah I
mean one of the things that comes
through is there's nobody there's no
pure good guys in this you know I think
some people she brought this well you
know some people wanted to say oh what
she's telling a story where the on Kali
are the good guys and look how bad human
beings are and that's it's not it's not
that simple
ya know when the humans I know they were
not allowed to reproduce Lee had taken
that away when they're gonna get their
own planet yeah which would mean that
they would have to somehow figure out
some way not through genes but through
culture to overcome the contradiction or
you know sooner or later than your
problem well either blow themselves up
again or figure out how to get off the
planet and then be a problem for
everybody else you know you know we
didn't get to that part yeah you know
the
okay it's come out in the vampire lestat
series she's written a new one and this
book touches on some similar themes she
she creates she releases a new race okay
a new set of creatures in this book and
are they connected with humans in any
way no they're connected with an alien
race who created them okay and there's
some very similar themes to what Butler
was doing in xenogenesis about human
beings being self-destructive yeah and
these other another life-form being sent
in to try to mediate some of it huh and
it's kind of just kind of it would take
too long to really completely describe
the yeah theme of the book but there was
some interesting parallels you know
something that just came to mind
somebody write it frequently teaches
Thomas Hobbes and Hobbes is you know
famous for saying life outside of you
know civil society is nasty brutish and
short but he gives reasons for why this
says and it kind of ties in with what
she's calling the contradiction Hobbes
says there's three fundamental motives
for human conflict one is competition
you know if you've got nice stuff I want
your nice stuff and so I'll attack you
and then another one is what he calls
vanity which is this wanting to be over
so and be higher than somebody else and
that fits in well with the the
hierarchical stuff but then the the the
the other one which is actually the
second that he says makes us super
dangerous is what he calls in his you
know 17th century English diffidence and
by that he means essentially like
strategic thinking like if I know that
you like my book and you're willing to
take it from me I better get the drop on
you because I know otherwise you're
gonna get the drop on me and the student
but I also know that you're you're like
me and so you are probably already
thinking oh he's going to try to get the
drop on me then he put all three of
these together and huh this is why
Hobbes in
his theory thinks you have a state of
nature that's really terrible and then
we have to have a a civil society with a
very strong authority to keep us from
monkeying around with each other and it
winds up being like a totalitarian state
so it's not a great solution but the
reason why he thinks it's so dangerous
is because you've got all three of these
working at the same time competition
vanity and diffidence and I think that
that fits in you know pretty well with
what she's describing and it sounds like
what you know what you're talking about
in the rice novel yeah and it seems like
part of what the Kali want to do is like
introduce like you might say some
breathing space so people can't do the
sorts of things that they normally would
do to each other I mean if you the
situations that they're placed in our
various state of nature right they they
get put out the Amazon they got to build
their own house and find food and you
know it sound like they're going back
into some technological city they're so
busy surviving they can't think about
killing each other they've gotta work on
the cooperation if they still manage to
spend well and one of the shortcuts to
survival is you know you find somebody
else who's doing the work survival and
then kill them and take their there you
know store of nuts or bananas or
whatever it happens to be and I think
that's what they're doing
yeah so let's talk about that yeah you
brought up that theme of like what is he
what is it to be human does it mean
having human DNA and not actually being
able to reproduce but at least you know
having sex the traditional way you know
man and woman no boy in the middle or
anything like that or is is is something
else you know what it means to be human
and do the OI the Roncalli get to have a
say in this or is it but or should it
just be just humans saying that
I mean the the resistors they called
them right the resistors their view is
anybody who's you know made this devil's
bargain they don't get to be part of
that discussion only the purebred humans
who haven't been modified and it was
like you know get tumors and things like
that only they should be able to decide
clearly that's not what what say Lilith
and her her brood think and then the
poor you know hybrids or constructs you
know they're born into a world where
they're not really fully human not
really fully all in Kali and and even
the on Kali and her like you got to
figure out what you're going to turn
into that's kind of kind of awful once
they go through their changes and they
look at lemon they start off looking
human and they sin they end up looking
moronic Allah with me yeah when they
grow those arms and stuff you know yes
second set of arms well you know there's
that one who the changes go really bad
with him like almost degenerates into a
girl almost like a mollusk or something
yeah things what she's not kidnapped
Ron had access to stimulus to help her
change yeah and she she was deprived of
what she needed to make the trip
metamorphosis yeah but I mean she likes
certain regrets me to the point where
she ate she just wanted to not exist she
never really did come back to anything
yeah I mean she came back to something
but never their full yeah so what do we
think about this human thing what did
what let's say we were in this world
would you guys be resistors which you
guys be I don't know the essentially
collaborators you know how would sort of
attitude would you have towards these oh
and Kali and constructs and other humans
well I probably be I'd probably go along
that's just creepy as I probably would
find that a better way of life because
the the resistors everything was just so
desperate you know just the survival was
so desperate and and there was always
that aggression and anger and resentment
that you had would just be there where
you know yeah you've got the lilulu a
guy there but but there was a
peacefulness and kind of a pleasure if
you're sick you got well which is kind
of cool yeah and then because that was
the first generation right yeah was
never comfortable with it yeah she
always was uncomfortable with it but
decided to do it yes it was their choice
but she's making a decision to for the
human races well there's a picture that
way yeah but then the later generations
adapted and bought into it as a way of
life I was just gonna come at that you
know this is yeah and if we go back in
time read a lot of races that we would
say were subhuman native peoples you
could say only people's a sense yeah or
whatever in and and so it wasn't so much
and they were declared sort of not human
but they were really declared as not
Christian or not the I they were the
other yeah you know and it was the I
that was like me whether we were the
chosen whether we were the saved but it
may have come originally from this
self-protective nature that says we you
know if we left the the chaos into our
domain then who knows oh no they must
convert
first somehow and not too much to be
human but just to be more like I and
less like the other and in this sense
it's being defined as human but we
clearly said native peoples were
subhuman I mean that's why we could
destroy them they weren't Christian they
weren't saved or whatever and you go
back through before history and similar
things were done a religious wars I mean
because there were the saved in the
chosen and interracial relationships and
and multiracial children because yeah
about the time she was writing it we
were still fighting this progenation
laws in the south oh yeah
the loving Supreme Court decision rather
than these yeah I think it was late
seventies early eighties it was so at
the time she's writing this we're still
finding the issue of if you mix a person
of a black person you get this thing
right right that's not me though because
when they were having all kinds of fun
in slavery times though well that's
that's why the you know and so what
she's doing in her narrative
world then is not just having you know
people of all different races you know
sort of thrown together and mating with
each other so that it might be you know
look as a black woman you know and she's
attracted if I remember right the first
guy she's attracted is Japanese and then
he gets killed and then there's others
so you've got all of that but then you
introduce a higher level of
miscegenation which is now you're mixing
with these aliens so some of the critics
have been like she not only manages to
like talk about interracial stuff but
and and they they use the word
bestiality I don't think that's right
because they're interesting cuz this you
know bestiality would be like little
lower species right rather than with
another intelligent species but you know
she's like really throwing the gauntlet
because it's not just Star Trek work
where you know maybe her and check off
could could kiss and you know people go
this is terrible but you know but it's a
it's an alien race
well I start Star Trek and of course
wasn't yeah you're right well no Kirk
green women from yeah yeah I think oh
yeah I well in my case it's Chanukah
it's kind of it's kind of funny because
mine came up you know completely
European but because you know this is a
total digression but because I have a
Jewish family name which isn't our real
family name
you know I occasionally get viewers who
will say oh I can tell his Jewish
physiognomies you know cuz Sadler's a
Jewish name my grandfather didn't know
because he was probably an anti-semite
or else he wouldn't have picked it but
he wanted something that sounded English
and that's that's a changing when he
immigrated no you changed he was born
here
he was Serbian and he wanted to get
ahead in business back in the 1920s and
there was a lot of prejudice against
Slavs at the time so he changed it to
sadler he just picked something that he
thought sorry I'm really English adopted
family that's true yeah yeah the funny
thing is is that so the people who like
save that sort of stuff if they were to
do their 23andme they probably find all
sorts of stuff in their background from
from the perspective that they have I'm
probably more Arian you know using their
categories than they are but they of
course they they don't they don't see
that and so they'll say stuff like I can
look at your forehead and see you know
that you're Jewish for it and I'm like
wow you're like this big in the UK
basically spot like important and the
23andme like your map is like well I've
got some Scandinavian and some right
what I'm saying is it's like it's
literally right there yeah that's pretty
much it so you can't get much
in the traditional sense well if you are
Slavic that was a pretty tight crowd no
you that was my that was your adopted
family yeah so yeah my my adoptive dad
was Serbian and polish but well there
was also the HS is shifting daily
because as the database is build they
get more accurate right now and so the
base is filled out there are parts of
the world I hit my mother side families
from Sicily that database is too small
to be accurate right now well and
Sicilians of cars are kind of a mixture
from yeah yeah the nor the the Norse
were there for a while they conquered
Sicily yeah but you know I'm so going
back to the back to this you know and
let's talk about the gene trade some
more what is it that they really like
about you know sucking up these genes
it's it's you know the sort of stuff
that we tend to obsess about in terms of
race it's pretty trivial stuff you know
like determining how your nose is or I
mean skin color can help out a little
bit you know how much you can be in the
Sun or not but compared to an alien
species you know or even really if you
think about just comparing us as a
species to other species that aren't
alien because they're they're from our
planet but they're they're different
from us if we if we made that the
contrast instead of what she's calling
this hierarchical behavior we probably
would be a lot it would be a lot easier
for us to get along with each other you
know what we don't I guess is how we
define humanity - oh yeah we you know we
come up with a commitment of terms as
what is human yeah this is what we're
gonna say is human and beyond that is
not but it's again it's constructed it's
just what we long as you're not part of
my tribe let me ask
chucking human in Jetta what would make
those any for the other this is a
functional need to have a other because
it unites the I yeah yeah but that's
travels but I'm looking at pure humanity
what would make you what we would
consider a human be you know I mean we
also these people now are doing sort of
do itself do-it-yourself gene
manipulation and I don't know if there's
anything really to what they're doing
right now but but sooner or later
there's gonna be more of that going on
so if I like enhance myself in some way
get it's a getting rid of a gene for
cancer am I making myself less human by
doing that or does that still like
within the range of tolerance because
I'm gonna keep adjusting as we keep
adjusting what if I decide that I want
my eyes to be like able to see colors
that human beings can say well no I mean
we still consider qualities that we to
say what is human you know it's we just
have this list of things and it will
they adjust as as we you know you all or
not yeah and you know what was something
you know Anthony and throw Pittacus or
whatever was that human not quite
because we decided they've never
exploited and if this intelligence they
didn't this big of a cranium by the time
you got to almost eight you know we we
have made is a list of things that we
consider human whether its emotions its
intelligence is Jean Casarez dangerous
look because you can usually find
somebody who's missing some of that and
then and then we get that sort of like
okay we can it's okay to get after them
you know like if we if we picked say
having empathy you know was philip k
dick really really liked that as sort of
a measure of being human it shows up in
a number of his stories but there are
people who lack empathy should we then
say well they're they're not human the
way the rest of us are well that's it
[Music]
emotions and they have family or family
structures and they have all of these
things to them and they have all of this
kind of thing and they have self-healing
in the mid kindig tool system extent but
they don't have intelligence so we come
up with out they don't have a level of
intelligence we think that's right just
or or or salon or some are
self-conscious I mean that kind of thing
we're not like self-aware so I think we
these are just you know characteristics
that we have defined as human know will
they change as we define the I in the
night for protection but human is a
definition well I am I define human you
define human his Hawaiian if I invoke
most cultures most cultures are
ethnocentric you know I mean it's
interesting because you look at any
highly developed culture up until recent
times and they all like have words for
like themselves as the human beings and
everybody else is like the barbarians or
some humans or you know the brexit
people foreigner you get rid of the
immigrants yeah France yeah oftentimes
they're different in other ways that's a
lie
yeah but oftentimes that fits in with
the hierarchy thing too because there's
this sort of sense with the
anti-immigrant they're getting over
somehow they're getting special
treatment so that needs to stop and you
know kick them out which is the
competition yeah I mean it's it's it's
interesting one of the trouble points
for us as well there's there's a number
of professions where if we want to be
really really strict about immigration
we'd be screwed
you know forget doing any any AI stuff
because you're gonna need a lot of
computer science people and we don't we
don't generate enough of them here so
you know South Asia is supplying us with
a lot or doctors or you know quite a few
other providers yeah so I don't think
we'll ever actually sort this out
discrimination as they say anti-human I
died there still people they're not
there but they're just disappear well I
think I think quite some of the people
who are anti-immigration speak with a
rhetoric that that shows that they think
that the immigrants are not human oh
yeah they're they're not human you know
in the same sense that whatever group
they're favoring is okay you want
something from someone like like he
wanted slavery they were creating
separate word whatever three-fifths of a
person we just give you determine that
is society because uh we needed to
subjective or objective primal well but
even beyond that during the civil rights
era if you were in the South it was
being preached from the pulpit was those
people are human that blacks were what
is intelligence
there's no people there's some people
doing that groups yeah they take the
view that will our group is better so
they're lesser so scientific insight
because I you know cuz I have a science
think so
this should be like me I'm in control if
they want to come here my analytical
brain that's too hard for me to do but
I'm saying yeah what your servers that's
I the letter I meaning or we had just
declaring somebody else's persona non
grata
I mean yes thing you know you're in this
head of cable and this is a bit so I
mean some over here
because he runs the spectrum for
discrimination - you're an animal
I mean here's the thing it could be that
it could be the case that it is from a
rational perspective irrational and yet
be an integral part of human nature that
we keep on doing this because you know
it does seem to be something almost like
a cultural constant across cultures that
you know there's somebody singled out as
as as the other as the ones who we don't
have - yeah and you're right it is
irrational yeah I mean our higher
intelligence should be able to get us to
the point where we can recognize that
this is irrational but because of the
hierarchical nature people are also able
to exploit it you know I mean you think
about like what what functional good
does say you know traditional anti black
racism do for the poor white southerner
I mean at one point they could say well
I'm better than than a black man but
that was purely illusory I mean they
were totally getting screwed by by the
people who who had power and now in the
present I don't even think that's there
there's you know the only thing is a
purely imaginary benefit and you can say
wow that that's totally irrational and
yet when you go and you point that out
to some people they're like no that
that's good enough for me you know yeah
and you know that's yeah I mean the the
prospects for I mean here's here's
another good idea would it actually take
having an alien race to come here and
sort of impose tough on us to sort
through this kind of stuff er or can we
or can do we do we really have a chance
of like making real progress so that you
know I'm not saying we wouldn't want to
discriminate in any way like if people
commit crimes I think we'd probably want
to put them in prison right people are
you know horrible to each other I think
we probably do want to be discriminating
in that respect but any sort of like
yeah I mean at this point racial
discrimination
you know I'm happy that I live in a time
where I think the people who understand
things well say that's that's done you
know that should be over with yeah well
right it's not over with because there's
still plenty of people who get something
out of it or you know or you know also
have you know experiences draw the wrong
conclusions from it but would it take
would it taken actually having aliens
come in and say okay we're fixing things
because you humans are too stupid to
aren't too intelligent and to
hierarchical to actually get things
right like us-soviet
like yes yeah like they were the great
enemies of each other yeah in many ways
but I think over time had the antithesis
kept on going on and on and on then both
sides would become more and more unified
in our I guess the United States racial
things become more together look at
something like the mom that came over I
mean they've been degree yeah stream lis
well compared with people who did not
have that same we are analyzing war
against a common enemy
there's some sort of adversary there's
some sort of I don't want to say like a
great wall that says no I'm trying to go
with it feel like there's like this
great gold to be had and it's something
that's more tangible that somebody can
actually put their finger on and talk
about some great project you're gonna
fly against a common enemy at your hands
could there be something else likes a
project well like like going to the
Stars right could we could instead
instead of like we're gonna fight those
bastards over there could it be
something like I don't know we're gonna
we're gonna clean up the oceans or we're
gonna wait I mean if the bee population
actually does get decimated okay and
option you know people are gonna have to
get over all sorts of tribal issues that
they want to eat and survive well I
think environmental things are going to
be a massive pressure in that that
respect I mean that's what I'm saying so
that's our solution yeah and I mean one
of the solutions is let's find some
other people round them up and kill them
off and maybe we can get some resources
out of them which is what we've done
that's what I'm thinking if we do it
they're getting very mental pressure
there's too many people with guns it'll
just take the thing out but if they want
you know unfortunately I don't know but
that's only a single generation that
doesn't actually solve the issue yeah I
think that's I mean that's sort of like
the zombie apocalypse like you're just
trying to stay alive for now
it's not actually world buildings or
allowing for any kind of like you know
future generative properties because
they're doesn't solve the problem I eat
but my children don't eat it if you look
at body of science fiction of
speculative fiction there were an awful
lot of the storylines humanity doesn't
make the shift until we nearly wipe
ourselves out Frank Herbert's books
happened after a war that decimates the
human race against machines yes the
Machine Star Trek Star Trek this
humanity on earth doesn't rise until we
wipe ourselves out you know
nuclear war oh we have when it begins to
rise again after a nuclear war yeah
and the Vulcans show up to go we get
their way Wow
that happens yeah that that storyline
it's we wipe ourselves pretty close to
wipe ourselves out in a nuclear war and
then we come back then we're more
tractable right yeah and that seems to
be a theme and an awful lot of science
fiction story lines
yeah a fiction story lines if humanity
doesn't ever overcome this until they're
nearly white nearly wiped ourselves out
yeah but that's very human though this
view of human characteristic it's hard
to change until you're almost done
desert door and then that's
that's just for changing a lot of times
it let's just think well you really need
to change it and until you're just about
there say okay now I'm going to finally
change my diet or do this or not
whatever the heck else but it it usually
or if somebody has got a really deep set
you know ISM of whatever the heck and
and then all of a sudden something will
happen to them that's so detrimental
that they can change but it takes
something
I mean after 9/11 this country kind of
came together after that for a little
while very short well that seemed to me
something that we could have we all sort
of you know the shock of it rally you
know the country for a bit there was
also a bit of oh let's let's go get
those bastards now though I think
uniting it to write you know your every
is afraid now so we now we can take away
some you run that well that well that
all happen to it but again was all
happening do the the event itself was
such a shock that for us a brief period
of time it did bring the country
together
getting back to what you're saying
before that's correct that there's a
sense of massive doom and gloom that we
use this way what a science fiction let
me ask the question when do you think
the the term science fiction first
really started being used oh yeah I want
to write that sort of stuff
both in the science technology so well
yeah after the bomb was developed to
anticipate the bomb before we had oh
yeah so but it was still the idea of the
bond that we could annihilate the planet
within our power not rationally managed
I don't remember who this was but I
remember coming across it recently there
was somebody
it was a pulp writer in science fiction
who was writing and he got enough things
right sort of by
chants about the Manhattan Project that
they actually told them not to write
anyway do you remember who it was no but
he uses her like speculating about how
this might work yeah and he you got it
right and somehow the military
authorities found out you know but yeah
I mean they they were in the the stuff
from the like 28 30s there were already
people thinking about like you know
weapons that could like destroy a whole
planet you know so it's it's being
theorized about and of course you know
Lovecraft in horror has like monsters or
things that could like destroy the
entire human race as well
there's also early religious writings
where the people or beings that came
from other places were simply you know
either angels or prophets from afar we
haven't mind that's a world idea yeah at
least for this world well yeah sex with
the ages you know yes especially around
the Year 1000 yeah but by the time they
start freaking out about okay the next
year is actually gonna be 1,000 it was
actually 1016 in reality yeah it was
like the Julian calendar like yeah well
then they were there was the the whole
you know Milan arias movement from like
the 1840s Miller and then you know a
bunch of other they kept on having to
revise the date you know others there's
other I mean that there are other groups
but what was the thing you had in mind
though they you know super powerful
beings destroying things or well I mean
it's not so much super powerful beings
destroying things but
entire judeo-christian mythology around
angels and I mean that's very much about
beings from another realm and we go to
this other realm of for well-behaved Oh
like heaven in hell you mean yeah I mean
you know it's it's a little bit
different but the idea that there is
somehow this other way of existing in
the universe and we can either earn it
or not yeah you know I mean I would say
that to your point about humanity and
and not being willing to change until
things are cataclysmic I think that's it
sort of predicated on a certain amount
of like socio-economic comfort though
because I think that that's the kind of
lifestyle a person can adopt if most of
their needs are actually being met so I
think that that in and of itself isn't
enough to be a human characteristic
because there's plenty of people who
aren't saying like yeah I'm gonna wait
and so I'm really really angry before I
find food or I'm gonna wait until the
wells almost dry and then over looking
for water
I mean it's that's what kind of like in
a village like that there's usually like
one or two guys who are like yeah you
know the this is this Wells not gonna
last forever and everyone else is like
we'll worry about that later
you know don't talk about that too much
and we're gonna throw you down the well
you know don't say self
self-preservation is is certainly a
human characteristic even though we do
so many things that yeah our destruction
of the drugs right once humans tend to
reach a level of feeling safe and secure
there's a tendency to just let it be
right I mean we have we have a lab mix
who will eat as if she were starving to
death as many labs I guess do anything
it's kind of a strange dogs dude she
would eat herself to death if we just
kept giving her food she would have no
problem I don't think she'd stop no
probably and that's you know I mean that
she's near needs that's a trait of the
species right dogs most dogs that do
that but there are those of us people
who are in danger of doing this thing
same just by not dealing with issues of
weight or health or whatever there are
people who have like other they smoke
through a tracheotomy yeah yeah
miss DOMA yeah I mean it's amazing it's
the number one well that's a romantic
thing about the freighter Cancer Center
when you go in there is that it just
reeks of cigarettes oh really
I mean now in Montreux 2017 it's a
phenomenon but I can't even understand
so I mean it's you know yeah the self
preservation and self destruction which
way we're like I would say I'm just so
addicting that the part of the brain I
mean they even had they've done so much
- yeah yeah but I mean even with people
that were looking at AIDS patients early
on when they were just starting to come
out with these cupcakes these cocktails
and they were offering them a catch-all
for their aids our cigarette and they
took cigarettes because the brain said
you are you you can live without food
you can live without all the stuff that
you cannot live without me right your
brain is telling you that whereas oh and
there's and that's that's what addiction
you know it and it just
what if we could be rebrand so that you
know addictive behavior addictive things
couldn't actually turn into you know
that addictive complex with you know the
brain problems yeah Oh with directly
stimulate the pleasure centers well
there was there was a it wasn't one that
we're talking about Larry not I even had
that Ringworld thing and his main
character starts out as being I forget
exactly they call it but if somebody had
like Jack Han and he just like you know
they they connect directly to your
pleasure Center and stimulate it and of
course it is very debilitating because
once somebody starts doing that they're
never going to stop I don't remember
because it's been so long since I'm
looking at
there's something and she had like this
like like if you had it too much you'll
get like like you'll go after that for
like the rest of your life yeah the more
feeling that he's something like that
yeah it's there was this alien that was
with the girl that did it to some 200
year old chick that they found in some
spaceship those ready and they got her
basically addicted to the feeling
Oh his main character presidency Oh
interesting
yes I mean that was like the female like
counter in park was the other female
lead like left right before the hmm
spent so long since I've I've looked at
it I don't know that might be a one that
we ended up doing for her next year so
we should actually bring this to to a
close so this is a great ending to the
year we've got a lot of new tracks next
year coming up and thanks for all of
your participation and discussion
[Music]
you